les vidéos de l214 qu'on a vu paraître
donc dans les différents journaux
télévisés voilà ont montré des images
choquantes qu'on jeter le discrédit sur
l'ensemble de la filière et notamment
sur notre beau métier d'éleveur donc on
l'a plutôt mal vécu c'est des images
qu'on ne devrait pas voir c'est ce qui
se passe dans les abattoirs et pas
forcément tout le temps réjouissances et
pour un lieu de fête on le sait après
les maltraitances qu'ils peuvent y avoir
lieu sont forts sont condamnables
les vidéos vues sont choquants que ça il
n'y a pas de doute dessus on ça ne
devrait pas se passer ce qu'on voit sur
les vidéos après on a toujours peur
qu'il s'agisse de montage de deux choses
qui ne se passe pas au quotidien est
vraiment d'actes isolés on stigmatise
une
une profession et je trouve ça plutôt
navrant parce que je pense que dans
l'ensemble les gens qui travaillent dans
les abattoirs ont plutôt du mérite et
travail de dans des conditions qui sont
pas forcément bonnes enfin dans des
conditions dures les personnes qui
travaillent ont le mérite de le faire et
les font très bien leur travail dans 99
points 9 % des cas après la nature
humaine fait que ba de temps en temps il
ya une faille et voilà il ya tout le
temps des gens pour tirer parti de ces
failles mais c'est c'est dommage on nous
pose souvent la question de est-ce que
vous respectez le bien-être animal
le bien-être animal on n'a pas
l'impression de faire quelque chose de
particulier parce qu'au quotidien on est
au contact de nos animaux et on fait
tout pour que nos animaux soient le
mieux possible crise ont nourri à
volonté ils sont propres ils sont ils
ont la place de se tourner si c'est
l'hiver ils sont en bâtiment pour être
au sein plutôt d'être dans la boue si
celle ci c'est l'été ils sont dans les
pâturages
ils sont dans l'air milon
ils ont tout ce qu'ils ont besoin on vit
avec la nature et de la nature quoi et
donc toutes ces bêtes qui vivent souvent
dix ans à qui on veut faire des vos cd
bet auquel voilà on prête beaucoup
d'attention quoi on n'a aucun intérêt à
faire faire en sorte que nos animaux
soient pas bien il ya forcément un
manque à gagner qui en découle il ya
forcément des complications sur le
travail a forcément tout un tas de
choses négatives qui en découle la
question est légitime de se poser la
question du bien-être animal c'est juste
que je pense que les gens se sont
éloignés des fermes ne viennent plus
voir ce qu'on fait au sein de nos fermes
et voit le mal
enfin on va pas dire le mal partout mais
ne connaissent plus notre métier et
c'est là le drame la mouvance vegan a
tendance à faire du tort les gens
écoutent c'est beaucoup relayé dans les
médias aujourd'hui quoi qu'on en dise
donc les personnes écoutent il ya très
peu de contradicteurs à partie au manque
on sème le discrédit sur une profession
on est il ya forcément un impact ce
qu'ils sont vraiment militants bon bah
on n'en parle pas on connaît leur
position mais après on jette le doute
sur le aux yeux des autres et puis sur
une profession capable cas déjà pas
besoin de ça la consommation ces héros
de tous les ans un petit peu alors est
ce que c'est le mouvement weygand est ce
que c'est le pouvoir d'achat est ce que
c'est
d'autres phénomènes les scandales
sanitaires dont on entend parler
régulièrement qui pareille sont éloignés
de nos élevages se retrouve à la marche
chez certains industriels donc lequel de
ces points-là héros de plus la
consommation une chose est sûr c'est
qu'elles baissent et que le mouvement
weygand n'y est pas pour rien la baisse
de consommation de viande n'est pas
forcément dû au fait du véganisme voilà
mais d'un point de vue moral
effectivement quand vous vous levez tous
les matin très tôt pour faire votre
métier et qu'on vous rabat matin midi et
soir justement voilà des propos qui sont
limite tolérable de façon sociétal c'est
pas toujours facile à vivre quoi les
critiques qu'on entend nous font de la
peine nous met en colère parce que pour
nous elles sont pas justifiées une fois
de plus les gens ne viennent pas voir ce
qu'on fait chez nous irons critiques
depuis très loin depuis les villes bien
souvent si des personnes ont envie de
pas manger de viande je les respecte
totalement
ils ont pas à les attaquer des
boucheries ou des gens qui font leur
travail et qui travaille très bien et
qui ne demandait rien à personne
on n'a pas besoin on sait pas ils ont le
droit d'avoir des convictions et on a on
est dans un pays où tout le monde a ses
propres droits et on a droit on n'a que
les obligations de respecter les droits
des autres l'éleveur a un impact sur
l'environnement quoi on peut pas voilà
et exploiter la nature et dire qu'on n'a
pas d'impact mais j'aimerais rappeler
que la vérité de l'élevage bovin en
france c'est un impact positif l'élevage
français qui plus est de viande rouge 2h
allaitantes et bon pour la planète
aujourd'hui on est des stockeurs de
carbone quand on parle de bilan carbone
tous les jours le bilan carbone de
l'élevage français est positif et on
voudrait nous faire croire le contraire
et on prend référence des élevages
lointain
d'amérique du sud on va ramener des
images de ce qui se fait de mal dans
d'autres pays que ce soit de l'élevage
ultra intensifs en argentine que ce soit
des des poulaillers ultra intensifs en
chocolat ou dans n'importe quel pays on
va comparer salasc hisser en france
alors que ça n'a rien à voir en france
on a une des agricultures les plus
protectionnistes et les plus
respectueuses de l'environnement qui
peut y avoir de par le monde
et puis je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça
qu'il faut voir l'impact carbone de la
viande il peut être négatif que
lorsqu'il est très impacté par les par
les transports donc
donc voila quoi et notamment la
suppression de l'élevage français
reviendrait à supprimer toute la
biodiversité et le beau paysage de
bocage conte à quoi faut avoir confiance
dans nos agriculteurs français et puis
faire en sorte que le bac le produit
français soit réellement valoriser parce
que si demain on massacre dont
agriculture française demain on aura
plus le choc de consommer ce qui vient
d'ailleurs et puis non réglés on n'aura
plus le choix de commencer fabriqué il
faut savoir parler aux consommateurs
qu'aux consommateurs quotidiens qui lui
se pose les vraies questions quoi et qui
sont tout à fait légitimes et dont je me
pose les mêmes c'est à dire en tant que
père de famille aux consommateurs quoi
il ya une grosse lacune sur la
communication depuis depuis depuis
toujours l'agriculture
enfin disons que dans le temps
l'agriculteur avait pas besoin de
communiquer puisqu'il avait tout le
monde à vannes agriculteurs dans sa
famille tout le monde savait comment ça
se passait aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'à
et puis la population des villes c'est
de plus en plus éloignés de la
population des campagnes et
il ya un gros fossé qui s'est creusé de
la meilleure des publicités qu'on peut
se faire ces deux c'est justement de
juste remonté ray notre métier quoi ça
suffirait en nettement à clarifier les
choses il faut savoir faire le tri dans
la dans la masse d'informations qui peut
être publiée n'importe où prendre le
temps de décortiquer et puis si vous
êtes à la campagne est allé voir votre
voisin comment ils travaillent ce sera
devant la première des choses puis si
vous êtes à la ville poussé le pied
jusque dans la ferme j'ai le moral et
j'essaye de garder le moral parce qu'on
a tellement un beau métier avec plein
d'atouts faut qu'on ne peut être
qu'optimiste et la nourriture
ça ne paraît pas être un sujet important
pour bien des gens mais malgré tout
c'est la base de la vie donc je pense
qu'on reviendra rapidement aux
fondamentaux